ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو القائم
باعمال السفاره السودان لدى السعوديه مهند
عمر عباسي مهند مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه الخاصه للعربيه بدايه اسالك كيف
تنظر السودان للدوري المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اليوم في الاسماء السودانيه
بشقها الانساني
شكرا جزيلا في البدء دعني اخي نايف اترحم
في بدء على ارواح الارواح السودانيه التي
فقدت جراء هذه الازمه الاخيره
المجد والخلود لشهدائنا في السودان شهداء
القوات المسلحه شهدائنا من المواطنين
السودانيين ونتمنى ايضا عاجل الشفاء
للجرحى والمصابين
قبل ان ندلف الى الى الدور المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
اسمح لي في البدء ان اتحدث عن هذه الاحداث
ربما يتساءلك كثيرون عن
ماذا حدث او ماذا يحدث في السودان
حقيقه هذه الاحداث التي بدات في السودان
في 15 من شهر ابريل الشهر الجاري كانت
احداث مفاجئه جدا الم يتوقعها اي احد سبب
عدم التوقع انهاء في نفس اليوم الذي حدث
في هذه الاحداث المؤسفه كان هناك اجتماع
سيتم بين رئيس فخامه السيده فخامه الفريق
اول ركن عبد الفتاح برهان رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقائي الانتقالي وراء القائد
العام للجيش السوداني
رئيس قوات
الدعم السريع هذا الاجتماع كان
يختص بمناقشه موضوع دمج قوات الدعم السريع
في القوات السودانيه ولكن طبعا شروط خاصه
سبحان الله يعني فجاه انقلبت الامر الى
محاوله التمرد محاوله قلب النظام السلطه
ونتج عنه الاحداث التي تابعتونها جميعكم
في
نعم نتج عنها هذه الاحداث وبالطبع وجود
مشكله كبيره بالنسبه
حدثت مشكله في المعاجر
توقف مطار الخرطوم الدولي لانه كان من اهم
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه للقوات المتمرده او
القوات المتفلته ضرب المصالح
الضرب الاماكن المهمه في السودان ضرب
القصر الجمهوري مطار الخرطوم الدولي
المنشات الحيويه مؤسسه
الكهرباء المياه فمن ضمن هذه
الاماكن التي تم ضربها مطار الخرطوم
الدولي
تسبب الاول اليوم الاول تسببت هذه الاحداث
كلها في وجود مجموعه كبيره من
العالقين ان رجعنا الى موضوع السؤال
العالقين في السودان الذين كانوا من جهات
من بعض
السفارات والمنظمات
والحمد لله بحمد الله تعالى
في هذا الصدد ايضا اتقدم بالشكر الى وزاره
الخارجيه السودانيه الى معالي السيده
الوزير معالي السيده الوكيل وكل الاخوه
الزملاء العاملين في وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه ليهودهم الحسيسه والكبير
والمقدره قامت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه
بتلقي العديد من البلاغات من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه والهيئات والمنظمات
بحدوث اعتداءات على مقرها قامت وزاره
الخارجيه بالتواصل مع جهات السودانيه
القصه لتامين هذه المقر
ساهمت الوزاره الخارجيه السودانيه في
تامين ايضا خروج اعضاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه والمنسوبين لها الذين يعملون
في جهات اخرى والحمد لله تعالى يعني تم تم
تامين خروج امن لهم عبر المعابر البريه
والجويه كم عدد الدول تقريبا التي ابلغت
وزاره الخارجيه بانها تعرضت مقرها الى
اقتحامات او محاوله السيطره عليها العديد
من السفارات ابلغت هناك اعتداء على داخل
المقال هناك اعتداء على الكاميرات
المراقبه خارج هناك تداعى على الموظفين
يتدل على السيارات ضرب نار وفي هذه
المناسبه نترحم على روح الله
الموظف السفاره المصريه
في الخرطوم الذي راح
هو نائب الملحق الاداري الملحق الاداري
وهو يعني
نتاسف يعني قلوب يعني تعازين الحاره
لاسرته الكريمه في جمهوريه مصر العربيه
الشقيقه
نحن نتاسف لهذا هذه الاحداث
سيد عمر ماذا عن وضع مهند عفوا وضع
السودانيين العالقين في المملكه الان كيف
يمكن الحديث عنها كيف تم التعامل معهم من
التواصل معكم اولا التعامل ايضا مع
الحكومه السعوديه سواء من كانوا عالقين
موجودين في السعوديه او من كانوا اهمينا
بالذهاب الى السودان نعم ايضا هنا
يجب ان نتقدم بالشكر
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ممثله في جلاله الملك سلمان ابن عبد
العزيز خالد الشريفين
و العهد حقيقه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يعني قامت بدور كبير جدا سواء كان بالنسبه
للعالقين سواء كان بالنسبه للهدنه الان
موجوده في السودان وهذه الهدنه بالمناسبه
هي التي ساهمت في خروجها
في موضوع الادلاع دوره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالنسبه للسودانيه العالقين في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في البدء نريد ان نوضح العالقين الموجودين
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه قدموا الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لاداء الشعائر
شعيره العمره وزيره المدينه المنوره وهذه
الاحداث تزامنت في الايام الاخيره من شهر
رمضان المعظم وهذه الايام الايام المباركه
من اكثر الايام التي يعني يرغب السودانيين
دائما في تواجدهم في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في هذه الايام المباركه صادفت
هذه الايام حدوث هذه الاحداث المؤسفه
والتي ناسف ان تحدث في هذا الشهر الكريم
مجموعه كبيره من العالقين وجدوا انفسهم في
يعني في وضع لا يمكنهم من العوده الى
السودان سواء عبر الطريق البحري او سواء
طريقه طائرات لاغلاق مطار الخرطوم الدولي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه نشكر لها جهودها
في توفير السكن والايواء وتقديم الخدمات
الطبيه ايضا لاعاده كبير جدا من المواطنين
السودانيين
وقامت اللجنه العربيه السعوديه بتشكيل
لجنه الان في تواصل كبير جدا معهم من دون
ذكرى اسماء يعني
وهذه اللجنه تواصلت معنا في السفاره
السودانيه بالرياض ولكن تواصلها الكبير
ايضا كان عبر القنصليه السودانيه العامه
بجده
باعتبار انه العالقين يعني مجموعه كبيره
جدا منهم موجودين الان في جده اعتبروا
الميناء البري
وايضا اذا سمح لي الوقت في هذا اللجنه
تعنى بشؤون العالقين السوداني نعم نعم هذه
اللجنه كما تشكيلها خصيصا وتواصلت معنا
منذ بدا الاحداث
وتكفلت بايواء وسكن العديد من الاسره
السودانيه وايضا
يعني بعض الظروف الصحيه حصلت طبعا وايضا
تكفلت بها وهذا الامر يعني انا لا اريد ان
اتحدث عنه لانه ليس بغريب عن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هي دورها دائما رائد في
مساله الاحداث اسمع لي في دقيقه واحده ان
اتقدم ايضا بالشكر
القنصليه العامه السودانيه بجده وعلى
راسها الوزير المفوض القنصل العام محمد
حسن بعشوم والذي كان له واركان حربه او
الاسلاف الموجوده في السفاره لدورهم
الكبير ايضا في رعايه المواطنين
السودانيين واذكر ايضا
انهم يعني لا يوجد اي مواطن سوداني اتواصل
مع القنصليه العامه بجده او السفاره
السودانيه في الرياض الا ووجد كله عون منا
هل بداتم ترتيبات الاجلال السودانيين
الموجودين في السعوديه باتجاه بورت سودان
نعم بدانا بتنسيق مع سلطات السعوديه
المختصه هذه الاجراءات من ناحيه التسجيل
من ناحيه الترتيب والتنسيق والان يعني
بدات بدات اعداد الحمل لله في التحرك لانه
هذه كما ذكرت الهدنه المعلن الان سمحت
بوجود حركه بحريه
من بورسودان الى جده وبالعكس فبدات بعض
الاعداد
المواطنين السودانيين في التحرك والعوده
مره اخرى الى السودان عبر ميناء جده هل
هناك اعداد مقدره لاعداد السودانيين الذين
علقوا في السعوديه مع نشوب هذه الازمه
اذا جئنا للعداد تقريبا تقديريه تقديريه
يعني اعداد كبيره جدا يعني
بالالاف لانه انا ذكرت في مقدمه حديثي انه
هذه الفتره الذي حدثت فيها الاعداد هي
فكره يعني عشره اواخر من رمضان يعني هذه
ايام يعني معظم المواطنين السودانيين يحب
اعضاء هذه الايام في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فبالتالي وضع طبيعي انه تكون
اعداد كبيره جدا بالالاف يعني انا لا احب
ان اذكر عدد معين لكن اعداد كبيره صراحه
هل هناك من السفارات تواصلت معك شخصيا هنا
في السعوديه لترتيبات الاجلاء او للسؤال
ايضا عن يعني كيفيه خروج مواطنيهم او
بعثاتهم الدبلوماسيه الموجوده في الخرطوم
نعم حقيقه تواصلت معنا مجموعات كبيره من
الساده السفراء او الدبلوماسيين بالسفارات
الموجوده بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه حصرا
بالرياض لو ان نحن مختصين الرياض او
المنطقه الشرقيه
تواصلوا معه معنا والحمد لله قمنا بتوفير
التاشيرات الدخول لهم
ويعني ونحن عملنا ايام هذه الاحداث 24
ساعه في اليوم وكنا عندنا غرفه مناوبه او
غرفه طوارئ وكنا يعني هناك زملاء وايضا
يعني في هذه السانحه لعشيد باعضاء السفاره
السودانيه بالرياض فردا فردا من دون ذكر
اسماء لانه يعني كانوا يقعدون الليله في
السفاره هل تعلم ان هناك من كان يبيت يترك
اطفاله اسرته في السفاره الخدمه للمواطن
السوداني تواصلوا معنا العديد من السفارات
وقمنا بمنحهم تاشيرات دخول في نفس اللحظه
او في نفس اليوم يعني
فتحنا ابوابنا مشرعه كالعاده السفاره
سودانيه
هذه السفارات اعطيناها هذه التاشيرات
وطلبنا منهم ايضا
يعني كل من يريد تاشيره دخول الى السودان
غرض الاجلاء نحن 24 ساعه جاهزون لهم طيب
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معي هنا
باعمال السفاره السودانيه لدى السعوديه
مهند عمر عباس شكرا جزيلا شكرا لك شكرا
جزيلا شكرا شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات